welcome to cloud security basics a
series where we explain the
ins and outs of securing your
application on google cloud
sound fun then stick around because in
this episode you'll learn about
why you shouldn't log into a compromised
server instance
during a breach
greetings cloud detective last episode
you used google cloud's operations suite
to track down a compromised employee
but this time i have finally gotten into
your system
i really have i repeat i have
breached your system so riddle me this
what can you do about it now that i'm on
the inside
hurry up as fast as you can try to get
me out
before i swap all of the employee photos
with cat photos
okay so here's what we know brad actor
says he's breached my system
which is a strange thing for an attacker
to do
and i haven't received any alerts from
my monitoring system
maybe i should log in and see what i can
find
actually no that could be playing into
exactly what brad
actor wants i almost just made
a really big mistake and logged into the
compromised instance
but many attackers plan for this exact
response
and actually try to steal admin
credentials as they log in to fix the
breach
so a general rule here is to avoid
logging into a compromised server during
a breach
hmm so how can i see if brad
actor really did breach my system
without compromising it further
well luckily we've set up an external
store for our security logs
that we can still check out what
happened by putting our forensic
artifacts in a separate place
in this case a google cloud project we
can examine the problem
without alerting the attacker this lets
us better understand what's happening
and we can watch and record their
actions
to tip off local authorities if needed
we set this up by using google cloud
operations suites export feature
in combination with syncs which are
basically filtered exports for log
entries the supported destinations for
syncs can be
a cloud storage bucket a pub sub topic
a bigquery table or a cloud logging
bucket
so we created a sync in our application
program
the one broad actor says he compromised
and we copied those logs into a cloud
logging bucket
in our logs monitoring project we ended
up using a cloud logging bucket because
unlike logs data that's stored in cloud
storage
logs stored in cloud logging are indexed
optimized
and delivered to let you analyze your
logs in close to real time
another benefit of this approach is that
it allows us to set up a system
where we view all of our project logs in
one place
simplifying monitoring everything in our
cloud environment
looking through my logs i don't see any
suspicious activity
hmm i guess it's best just to be patient
and wait this one out and see if
anything does pop up
oh i got it
now that's just devious dratz detective
you foiled my plan it's true
i didn't fully breach your system but i
was hoping to steal your credentials
when you attempted to log
in it would have been a mistake to
immediately log into the supposedly
compromised server
but i know you would have examined your
audit logs which means you must have set
up a separate
security environment for your forensic
files well played detective well played
that's all from me for now but i will
come back
more devious and mischievous than ever
in the near future
so there you have it another episode of
cloud security basics
for more information about securing your
cloud environment
be sure to check out the links in the
description below
so stay tuned for the rest of the cloud
security basics series
because when it comes to security you
can't let bad actors win
[Music]
you